[Music]
hi my name is baba shiv i'm a professor
of marketing at the graduate school of
business
i've been teaching several courses over
the years but my favorite course
is the frinky signs of the human mind
now as a current and or future
organization leader
you have to be effective at two things
among others day in and day out
you have to be effective at making
decisions but even more
important i would argue you have to be
effective at shaping
others decisions and when we go about
shaping others decisions
what do we often end up doing we present
rational arguments
keep in mind that the rational brain
accounts for only about five to ten
percent of human decisions by all
estimates i'm not saying you can ignore
the rational side but first and foremost
you need to play into what the emotional
brain is looking for
you need to appeal to the emotional
brain you need to
weave into the value proposition things
that will bring about a feeling of
comfort this feeling of reassurance a
peace of mind
you want to bring in excitement kindle
the inner child in that person
discovery curiosity play
etc
[Music]
now as a leader trying to shape others
decisions trying to get a bind from
someone
remember the following number one who
does that individual
trust the most themselves
second remember that whenever the brain
perceives that it is making an
investment in something it gets invested
in it
number three there's a famous saying
here in silicon valley that if you're a
startup founder going to an investor for
money
you're going to get advice you go for
advice
you're going to get money so what you do
is that go to this stakeholder you're
trying to influence
you're trying to get a buy-in from and
what you do
is seek advice the person will provide
advice
now that person's brain has gotten
invested in your idea
now your idea will become that person's
baby as well
and finally when you're presenting this
to and seeking advice from this
individual
present a rough prototype not a polished
prototype
because when you present a polished
prototype
others will only find flaws when you
present a rough prototype
others will see potential
now whenever we are faced with tough
decisions
professional decisions personal
decisions we often end up
agonizing about whether we're making the
right decision
but remember in the real world there is
no such thing as making the right
decision
you make the decision and then make the
decision right
now to make the decision right we have
to be cognizant of two things
number one we have to be confident we
got to have this feeling of conviction
about the course of action that we're
going to take and that conviction
is rooted in emotion so go ahead make
the decision and
invoke all these positive emotions
construct a
narrative that showcases total success
that'll allow you to be confident but we
also need to be
cognizant of the various deterrents that
can derail us along the way
so that we can address those issues
before the issues actually arise
we all want to pursue a life
filled with passion having the juice to
pursue what
life has to offer us now keep in mind
that
in order to get the best out of life we
have to expect
the best out of life we got to have
these congruent beliefs this faith
that things are finally going to work
out in the end
why the whole notion of the placebo
effect
where our expectations turn into reality
and that's why it is in the anticipation
of happiness
that happiness itself resides it is the
anticipation of success
that success itself resides
as individuals we all want to leave a
legacy we all want to have an impact to
change lives to change organizations to
change the world out there
but to do that first and foremost you
need to take care of yourself
remember the safety announcement before
the flight takes off
put on your oxygen mask first
before helping others make sure that you
are healthy so that you can perform
at your peak you're a peak performer
leaving a legacy having an
impact on the world
my mom would have never expected that i
would have become a professor
of course nowadays she calls me up and
she says you know
look at your friends look at that friend
of yours who's become a
multi-millionaire
and look at you just a college professor